bueno en el vídeo anterior nos quedamos
en que tenemos la aceleración que es
igual a 10 metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado cuando estamos hablando de la
gravedad terrestre también esto lo
podemos usar con la letra g de gravedad
entonces ahora vamos a imaginar que le
hacemos una moneda desde un rascacielos
aunque nunca lo hagan porque podrían
matar a alguien digamos que aquí tenemos
nuestro edificio alto
un poco sueco pero bueno es un edificio
y aquí arriba tenemos a esta mala
persona que va a dejar caer una moneda
la va a soltar y la la moneda va a caer
en esta dirección
la moneda se va a acelerar en relación a
la gravedad y se va a acelerar hacia
abajo
a 10 metros por segundo al cuadrado
entonces comencemos con una pregunta
interesante después de dos segundos
digamos que el tiempo era igual a cero
cuando soltamos la moneda después de dos
segundos qué tan rápido irá entonces
tenemos que nuestro tiempo es igual a
dos segundos
y vamos a usar la fórmula
velocidad es igual a la aceleración por
el tiempo que es igual que nuestra
aceleración por la gravedad es 10 metros
por segundo al cuadrado
multiplicado por el tiempo de 2 segundos
multiplicamos los valores 10 por 2
y también no nos olvidemos bueno 10 x 12
20 que vamos a multiplicar también las
unidades entonces multiplicamos
metros por segundo entre el segundo al
cuadrado
y este segundo en el numerador me va a
cancelar a menos uno de estos dos
segundos multiplicados en el denominador
y nos queda con que la velocidad a los
dos segundos va a ser 20 metros por
segundo
después de veinte de dos segundos la
moneda va a una velocidad de 20 metros
por segundo
ahora les pondré un problema de un
poquito más difícil que podría no ser
tan obvio
después de unos segundos que tan lejos
ha llegado a la moneda eso es
interesante pues tenemos una fórmula que
nos dice que la distancia es igual a la
velocidad por el tiempo
pero la velocidad va cambiando conforme
pasa el tiempo
entonces bueno sabemos que después de
dos segundos nuestra velocidad es de 20
metros por segundo
vamos a llamar a esto nuestra velocidad
final v subíndice f que es una manera
elegante de decir velocidad final y
tenemos que es 20 metros sobre segundo
y además nos acordamos que la velocidad
inicial cuando íbamos a dejar caer la
moneda
nuestro tiempo era cero entonces cuál es
la velocidad o cuál fue la velocidad en
el momento en que resultamos la moneda
bueno si el tiempo era cero vemos que a
notificarse por la aceleración pues
nuestra velocidad velocidad subíndice y
velocidad inicial es igual a cero metros
por segundo
entonces bueno podemos usar esta fórmula
de distancia y la velocidad por tiempo
solo que vamos a usar oa calcular la
velocidad promedio
de la moneda
entonces como calculamos la velocidad
promedio esto solo lo podemos hacer
cuando tenemos una aceleración constante
y en especial cuando trabajamos con la
gravedad aquí siempre vamos a tener la
aceleración constante
entonces bueno normalmente el primer año
de física siempre van a haber problemas
donde la aceleración es constante sí que
pueden hacer una nota mental de usar
esta fórmula con la velocidad promedio y
como vamos a calcular la velocidad
promedio bueno tenemos nuestra velocidad
final de 20 eventos por segundo nuestra
velocidad inicial de 0 metros por
segundo y la velocidad promedio
v subíndices p de promedio va a ser
igual a la velocidad final
más la velocidad inicial inicial
entre 2 es el promedio no nos olvidemos
de usar las unidades entonces tenemos
nuestra velocidad final 20 metros por
segundo más 0 metros por segundo pues
nos sigue quedando aquí 20 metros sobre
segundo
entre
220 entre 2 nos queda 10 entonces
nuestra velocidad promedio es igual a 10
metros por segundo
y es nuestra velocidad promedio
entonces ahora si podemos hacer este
valor en nuestra fórmula de la distancia
justo cuando se suelta la moneda este
objeto está estacionario después de dos
segundos usamos la fórmula de
aceleración y la moneda tiene una
velocidad de 20 metros por segundo
durante estos dos segundos su velocidad
promedio fue de 10 metros por segundo
entonces usando la fórmula
de distancia en este caso es igual a la
velocidad promedio
por el tiempo
tenemos que nuestra velocidad promedio
es de 10 metros por segundo multiplicado
por el tiempo que es de 2 segundos
multiplicamos los valores 10 por 2 son
multiplicamos las unidades metros entre
segundos por segundo los segundos se
cancelan y nos queda que la distancia a
los 2 segundos es de 20 metros
después de los segundos no sólo mi
velocidad es de 20 metros por segundo
hacia abajo recordemos que estamos
hablando de velocidades y tenemos que
indicar la dirección si estuviéramos
hablando de la rapidez se podría decir
que son en este caso la velocidad final
es de 20 metros por segundo pero como
estamos hablando de velocidad tenemos
que indicar la dirección que es hacia
abajo
y la distancia en que recorrió la moneda
cuando la soltamos asumiendo que no hay
resistencia al aire esta moneda ha caído
20 metros
ahora veamos si podemos usar esto para
que tengamos una mejor intuición de
estos conceptos si están estudiando
física lo que no es necesario para
comprender estos vídeos pues esta es la
idea
quisiera mostrarles que esta es casi
exacta exactamente como una de las
fórmulas que verán en sus clases de
física y es una lástima que la gente
tiende a memorizar la sin llegar a
comprender de dónde viene esta fórmula
bueno recordemos que teníamos que la
distancia
era igual a la velocidad por el tiempo y
que la velocidad era igual a la
aceleración por el tiempo pero bueno
antes de regresar a esto vamos a
explayarnos un poquito más de por qué
estoy asumiendo que la velocidad inicial
es cero entonces vamos a ver que esta
velocidad
la velocidad final es igual a la
velocidad inicial ya que bueno ustedes
podrían estar viajando a 10 metros y
entonces comenzar a acelerar así que
tenemos que esto
la velocidad final va a ser igual a la
velocidad inicial
más la aceleración
multiplicada por el tiempo
y dijimos que la distancia que podemos
describir es igual del promedio de la
velocidad por el tiempo entonces tenemos
que la distancia
la podemos reescribir como que es igual
a la velocidad promedio
multiplicado por el tiempo
veamos si podemos usar estas dos
fórmulas para encontrar la fórmula de la
distancia dada a la aceleración por el
tiempo bueno sabemos que la velocidad
promedio
es igual a la velocidad final
más la velocidad inicial
entre 2
entonces cuál es la velocidad final
bueno la velocidad final es igual a esto
que sustituimos
vamos a sustituir esto en esta fórmula y
tenemos que la velocidad promedio es
igual a la velocidad inicial más la
aceleración por el tiempo
más la velocidad inicial
entre 2
y vemos que esto es igual
dos veces la velocidad inicial más la
aceleración por el tiempo entre 2
hacemos la división
y nos queda que la velocidad promedio es
igual a la velocidad inicial más la
aceleración por el tiempo
entre 2
y esto podría ser algo intuitivo para
ustedes ya que la velocidad promedio va
a ser igual a nuestra velocidad inicial
más la velocidad o la diferencia de
cuanto hemos acelerado en el tiempo
entre dos ya que estamos tomando el
promedio si lo que he dicho les confunde
no se preocupen pueden regresar y
revisar estos esas fórmulas poner
incluso algunos números para que tengan
un mejor sentido y lo comprendan mejor
encontraremos que la velocidad promedio
va a ser igual a la velocidad inicial
más la aceleración por el tiempo entre
dos es esta fórmula que acabamos de
encontrar
sustituyendo esta fórmula de la
velocidad promedio en nuestra fórmula de
la distancia
tenemos que la distancia es igual a la
velocidad promedio y la velocidad
promedio es la velocidad inicial más la
aceleración por el tiempo
entre 2
por el tiempo
y vamos a continuar con esta fórmula en
el siguiente vídeo ya que nos estamos
quedando un poco cortos en el tiempo